man stirbt an selbst angebauter zucchini
künstliches gehirn und deutsche forscher
stellen einen neuen rekord auf das sind
nur drei der fünf themen heute in den
klicks um top five news
in einem kieswerk oder einem steinbruch
findet man bestimmt so einiges über den
tag verteilt in hannover fand man jetzt
etwas sehr ungewöhnliches dinosaurier
fußabdrücke
wer hat sich als kind nicht schon einmal
gewünscht spuren von dinos zu finden
oder knochen
es war ja schon abenteuerlich re spuren
oder ähnliches gefunden zu haben
den wissenschaftlern die im steinbruch
in rehburg-loccum mehr als 90
fußabdrücke entdeckt haben ist wohl ein
kinderwunsch in erfüllung gegangen wie
groß muss man sich dann an solchen
abdruck vorstellen die dort gefundenen
haben einen durchmesser von sage und
schreibe mehr als einem meter
dieser außergewöhnliche fund soll jetzt
geschützt werden zitat das sind die
letzten langhals dinosaurier in dieser
region gewesen wir haben nur diese eine
spur gefunden und wollen versuchen die
abdrücke vor ort zu erhalten so annette
richter vom niedersächsischen
landesmuseum hannover neuer rekord
wissenschaftler haben es geschafft eine
supraleitung bei minus 70 grad celsius
herzustellen
das ist für die forscher fast
zimmertemperatur bevor es den deutschen
forschern gelang lag der rekord
temperatur bei minus 100 9 grad celsius
ein supraleiter zeichnet sich dadurch
aus dass er keinen elektrischen
widerstand hat für den strom bedeutet
das dass er einfach so hin durch gleiten
kann ohne jegliche einbußen verzeichnen
zu müssen in der fachzeitschrift nature
veröffentlichten sie ihre erkenntnisse
sie übten auf schwefelwasserstoff h2s
einen gewaltigen druck aus der druck
hatte eine intensität von 1,5 millionen
atmosphären für uns laien eine absolut
unbekannte größenordnung aber es war auf
jeden fall sehr sehr viel von einem
supraleiter der bei raumtemperatur also
wirklich raumtemperatur seinen job macht
da träumen die forscher allerdings immer
noch aber minus 70 grad das ist
schließlich schon eine temperatur die
hier zuweilen auf der erde bevor kommt
also es ist doch eigentlich ein kleiner
weg um das zu schaffen und super leitung
ihr wisst dass vielleicht ist ein
riesiger technologischer fortschritt
damit ist es möglich strom über lange
strecken verlustfrei zu transportieren
wir vergeuden viel weniger energie für
den transport tierfotografen geben sich
immer stets mühe ihre models nicht zu
stören langsam und vorsichtig tasten sie
sich heran und fahrten teilweise
tagelang auf den perfekten moment
wissenschaftler sind da so scheint es
eher ungeduldig quadrocopter werden
zunehmend zur beobachtung wilder tiere
eingesetzt doch rentiert sich das
wirklich und was halten die tiere denn
davon ist es grundloser stress für die
tiere oder können tatsächlich wichtige
erkenntnisse durch die flügel gewonnen
werden wenn ja wie sehr leiden die
wildtiere darunter dieser frage widmeten
sich die experten der university of
minnesota instinkt paul ihre resultate
stellten sie in der fachzeitschrift
current biology vor
die experten starteten vier
amerikanische schwarzbären mit gps
sendern und einem herzschlag messer aus
dann kam das fluggerät zum zug ganze 18
mal startete der quadrocopter und machte
sich in ca 20 metern höhe auf den weg zu
den tieren bei seinen wilden probanden
angekommen verwaltet er dann dort
ungefähr fünf minuten nachdem fünf
minuten kehrte der quadrocopter wieder
zusammen ausgangspunkt zurück alle 18
flüge wurden genau dokumentiert jeder
der wilden probanden hatte in beisein
des charakters eine messbar erhöhte
herzfrequenz
diese resultate sollte man sich als
wissenschaftler vor einen quadrocopter
einsatz auf jeden fall durch den kopf
gehen lassen ist der einsatz stress
unrund oder ist der grund wichtig das
heißt sind die forschungsergebnisse die
dabei gewonnen werden können so wichtig
dass der stress für die tiere zumutbar
ist
vor einigen wochen berichteten wir ihnen
den tipp zum schluss von forschern die
eine künstliche ratten foto züchteten
jetzt scheint einem us-wissenschaftler
etwas nahezu unvorstellbare gelungen zu
sein
rené ahnung von der ohio state
university hat es ihm zufolge nach
geschafft ein gehirn zu kreieren das dem
eines 35 tage alten embryo es ähnelt das
gehirn würde zudem einen großteil der
gehirnregionen der zellarten und der
gene beinhalten mit einem künstlichen
gehirn könnte man demnächst im bereich
der neurologischen medizin auf
tierversuche verzichten
das klingt ja schon sehr überzeugend und
nahezu perfekt aber das gehirn besitzt
keine blutgefäße und wie ihr vielleicht
bemerken konnte in den letzten sätzen
kamen das des öfteren der konjunktiv
vorhätte würde könnte also mal abwarten
was uns da noch so erwartet
wer von euch hat denn einen eigenen
garten und baute auch gemüse oder obst
anmelden
ja also schon mal daran gedacht dass er
an selbst gebauten gemüse sterben könnte
das klingt ziemlich unwahrscheinlich
aber einem gärtner aus heidenheim ist
genau das passiert er starb an einer
selbst angebauten zucchini der 79 jahre
alte mann wurde in heidenheim in eine
klinik gebracht erste vermutung magen
darm beschwerden tatsächlich ist der
mann dann aber und das ist wirklich
schlimm an einer kubica ziehen
vergiftung gestorben
diesen täterschaft findet man
beispielsweise in einer zucchini melone
kürbis oder in einer gurke in geringen
mengen durch mutationen oder um günstige
wachstumsbedingungen genau weiß man das
noch nicht kann sich dieses gift aber
anreichern
die gewächse schmecken dann allerdings
super bitter maria roth ist leiterin des
chemischen und
veterinäruntersuchungsamts in stuttgart
kurz gvu ihr zufolge würden menschen das
bittere gemüse sofort aus dem mund
nehmen aber wie konnte dann der mann
daran sterben
dieser hat die zuglinie nicht nur
gegessen sondern in einem auflauf also
etwas abgemildert werden
neben dem cv untersucht nun auch die
staatsanwaltschaft ellwangen den fall
zitat es muss geprüft werden ob jemandem
ein vorwurf am tod des mannes gemacht
werden kann oder ob schicksal dafür
verantwortlich ist so ein sprecher der
staatsanwaltschaft ellwangen
in deutschland wird noch eine tödliche
gefahr umher nicht bittere zucchini
sondern aggressive mücken mehr zu der
gefährlichen mücken art erfahrt ihr im
video hier oben zu rap und zum block
kommt den hier unten und schreibt uns
doch mal in die kommentare ob ihr selbst
gemüse oder obst anbaut und ob er
bestimmte sicherheitsvorkehrungen
treffen bevor er das obst oder gemüse
ist oder wie sieht's mit pilzen war ich
aus wie geht ihr mit selbst geernteten
gewächsen um also schreibt es in die
kommentare ich bin auf eure antworten
gespannt und bis dann bleibt dran